Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es wird höchste Zeit, mal wieder auf die Serie A zu blicken und da kann es hier nur einen Gast geben im Rasenfunk, nämlich Christian Bernhardt, freier Journalist und unter anderem jetzt bei DAZN zu hören. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 99. Christian, servus.
Hallo Max, schön dich zu sehen.
Schön, dass du trotz deiner steilen Karriere noch Zeit für den Rasenfunk gefunden hast. Freu ich mich sehr.
Ja, ich glaube, das können wir jetzt mal ausklammern, aber ich freue mich einfach, dass ich hier bin und dass wir wieder mal ein bisschen über die Serie A quatschen können.
Ey, es wurde allerhöchste Zeit. Ich dachte irgendwie, wir hatten ja diese Ronaldo-Folge gemacht und die hatte ich irgendwie in die Saison reingelegt. Jetzt haben wir acht Spieltage schon in der italienischen Liga gespielt und noch nicht über die Serie A gesprochen. Wir beginnen völlig überraschend mit einem unbekannten Team aus Turin. Juventus heißen die, glaube ich. Die sind mir vor allem aufgefallen, weil sie acht Siege, kein Unentschieden, keine Niederlage haben. Bei 18 zu 5 geschossenen Toren, das scheint ja nicht so schlecht zu laufen bei denen.
Ja, damit konnte wirklich niemand rechnen, dass wir jetzt darüber auch sprechen wollen. Aber lass es uns doch einfach tun. Ich kann dir die hier nochmal googeln, wenn du jetzt vielleicht ganz kurz, dass ich da auch einen größeren Blick drauf habe.
Alles wie immer oder hat sich bei diesen acht Siegen irgendwas anders gezeigt als in den letzten Spielzeiten?
Ich würde sagen, einige dieser Siege waren gar nicht alles so deutlich. Also da waren wirklich auch ein paar Spiele dabei, wo sie jetzt nicht wirklich so dominant waren, wie man sie kennt. Oder auch, wie man sich vielleicht dachte, zum Beispiel in das Parma-Spiel oder auch beim Sieg gegen Sassuolo. Aber, und das glaube ich, ist wirklich eine neue Qualität. Und die hängt vielleicht dann auch mit diesem Namen, Christiano Ronaldo zusammen, ich glaube, das Selbstverständnis ist einfach noch mal ein dick größer geworden.
Ist das noch möglich?
Also eben wie gesagt, das war ja die letzten Jahre sehr klar, gerade auf Ligaebene, da kann man nicht drüber reden, haben die sich das über Jahre doch einen relativ hohen Standard dazu geholt. Aber durch den Christiano-Ronaldo-Transfer hat man halt gemerkt, glaube ich. Und ich glaube, das ging mehr so vom ganzen Vereinsumfeld aus. Also, dass die jetzt gemerkt haben, okay, jetzt machen wir noch mal einen Schritt. Wir sind ja schon sehr weit oben und haben ja auch gerade international schon dran gekratzt. Aber jetzt halt einfach, jetzt holen wir uns einen der zwei besten Spieler der Welt. Und dadurch hat sich das, glaube ich, auch in die Mannschaft halt noch mal mehr draufgelegt, positiv sozusagen. Und ja, deswegen haben die jetzt in der Liga sie ein paar Mal sehr beeindruckend gespielt, ein paar Mal nicht. Aber wenn sie nicht beeindruckend gespielt haben, haben sie es halt trotzdem gewonnen. Und ja, dann stehst du halt mit 24 Punkten nach acht Spielen da. Und das darf man ja nicht vergessen, das strahlt ja auch wieder auf die Gegner aus. Und die haben die letzten Jahre schon immer gedacht, ach Mist, Juve, wie komme ich da ran? Und jetzt siehst du halt, dass die wieder davon ziehen. Jetzt siehst du, dass die diesen CR7 auch noch haben. Ich glaube, dass das bei den Gegnern auch noch mal einiges auslöst.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Auch in der Champions League beide Spiele gewonnen, ohne Cristiano Ronaldo in Valencia 2 zu 0. Und gegen die Young Boys aus Bern 3 zu 0, also einzig und allein Siege bisher, so ein bisschen heraussticht da das Heimspiel am siebten Spieltag gegen Napoli. 3 zu 1 gewonnen. Da hätte ich jetzt gesagt, auch nachdem Neapel aktuell auch wieder auf Platz 2 steht, das war das wichtigste Spiel der letzten Wochen. Wie hat sich denn Juve da präsentiert?
Ja, definitiv. Das war es, wie du es eben sagst, weil auf Napoli kommen dann ja auch noch zu sprechen. Napoli macht das diese Saison auch wieder sehr, sehr gut. Das war logisch so ein Spiel, da konntest du halt ein Statement setzen, jetzt nicht nur ein Zeichen an Napoli, sondern auch in Sachen Punkte. Jetzt haben wir das ja genau. Jetzt haben sie halt einfach sechs Punkte Vorsprung. Obwohl Neapel das alles andere als schlecht macht. Das liegt jetzt weniger an der Schwäche von Neapel. Dementsprechend war das logisch sehr wichtig. Es war logisch ein Spiel, das davor schon sehr emotional diskutiert wurde, weil es ja letzte Saison in der Rückrunde den 1-0-Sieg in Turin von Neapel gab, wo man dachte, jetzt haben wir das Ding endlich. Dementsprechend war da logischerweise ein großes Fokus drauf. Napoli war ja auch in Führung, aber da hat man dann einfach gemerkt, dass Juve derzeit –ich habe das Gefühl, wenn sie müssen oder wenn sie müssen wollen, und sie wollen momentan definitiv sehr, dann können die gerade in diesen großen Spielen momentan wirklich was Selbstsicherheit, was Selbstverständnis, was auch die Automatismen betrifft, weil Allegri und der Kern jetzt schon viele Jahre da sind, einfach noch was draufbacken. Das haben sie da Neapel ziemlich eindrucksvoll gezeigt. Wobei man auch dazu sagen muss, es war dann am Ende ein 3-1, Neapel war in der zweiten Hälfte dann auch in Unterzahl. Aber bis das 3-1 fiel, hatte Neapel sogar in Unterzahl auch ein, zwei Chancen, das 2-2 zu machen. Also es war jetzt nicht so, dass die da drüber gefahren sind. Aber am Ende des Tagesgewinnens ist 3-1 und das ist das direkte Duell. Wenn man sich die Tabelle anschaut und auch die Geschichte der letzten Jahren, dann kann sowas halt wahnsinnig viel wert sein.
Der wievielte Meistertitel in Folge wäre das jetzt?
Der sechste, siebte? Hoffentlich komme ich jetzt nicht ins Schlittern. Also mindestens der siebte, wenn nicht der achte.
Stimmt, ich glaube, das stimmt.
Das ist eins mehr als bei den Bayern.
Genau, richtig. Und da wollte ich jetzt nämlich drauf hinaus. Denn wir erleben ja gerade bei den Bayern, da will ich nicht davon sprechen, dass da irgendwas zerfällt, aber die sind jetzt schon mehrmals ins Stocken geraten. Und vor allem in der Liga, weil man eben auch merkt, das wacht was mit den Spielern, dass sie das Gefühl haben, immer zu gewinnen. Jetzt schaue ich mir Juve an und die gewinnen alles. Kann man da eine besondere Einstellung im Kader ausmachen? Wie würdest du das erklären, jetzt auch im Vergleich zu der Situation, die wir hier haben, wo man zum Beispiel beim Bayern das Gefühl hat, das eigentlich Wichtigere ist, die Champions League?
Ich glaube, dass der ganze Verein über die Jahre, das geht los beim Präsidenten, bei Andrej Anjeli, der diesen ganzen Aufschwung mit eingeleitet hat, bei Marotta, bei Parati, die entscheidenden Verantwortlichen, was die Mannschaft betrifft und dann logisch bei der Mannschaft und beim Trainer selbst, irgendwie haben sie es wirklich geschafft, da so ein Gefühl herzustellen, dass sie einfach immer mehr wollen. Das klingt jetzt wie eine Platitüde, das ist mir schon klar, aber gerade in Italien wird auch sehr viel, es ist zum Beispiel diese Rekordtitel hintereinander, das ist eine relativ große Nummer in Italien. Also da wird sehr viel, wenn du sagen kannst, es wird sehr oft darüber gesprochen, ach, die großen Mannschaften von früher, aus den 60er-, 70er-Jahren, und Juve ist sich jetzt logisch bewusst, und die sind ja auch auf dem Weg dahin, dass die da selbst so eine Ära prägen, über die wahrscheinlich noch in, ich weiß nicht, 50 oder 100 Jahren auch noch geredet wird, zumindest in Italien, und das hat sich einfach so tief eingepflanzt, in den Kern der Mannschaft eben auch, dass das, glaube ich, ich würde sagen, das ist der Hauptgrund dafür. Dazu kommt, dass das Juve ja gerade in den letzten Jahren in der Champions League ja wirklich, ja, wie gesagt, zwei Finalteilnahmen, sonst auch immer relativ knapp, relativ spät ausgeschieden, einfach dieses Feuer da ist, dieses Ding halt endlich zu holen.
Ja, aber da lassen ja andere in der Liga dann schlafen.
Ja, aber das, glaube ich, und das wollte ich eben gerade sagen, das klappt halt bei Juve gut, dass die ganz genau wissen, das kann man nicht losgelöst voneinander betrachten. Die wissen, wir brauchen diese Sicherheit und diese Stabilität, die wir uns jetzt über Jahre in der Liga erarbeitet haben, die brauchen wir auch, weil das ist für uns die Basis, um dann eben auch in Europa sozusagen nochmal ganz oben anzugreifen. Und ja, wie gesagt, Allegri macht das sehr gut, wobei man ja sagen muss, das ginge davor mit Konte, logisch auch schon los. Also ich glaube, es würde jetzt, also wobei Allegri logisch das jetzt sehr gut fortgeführt hat. Und dann ist halt einfach dieser, ich glaube schon auch, dass es ein besonderer Spieler-Kern ist. Also diese Juve haben jetzt ja mittlerweile sehr viele große Namen verlassen. Klar, Buffon, Pirlo, Del Piero, wenn wir ein paar Jahre zurückgehen. Aber da sind halt immer noch so Spieler wie Chiellini, wie jetzt auch Bonucci, der wieder zurückgekommen ist, die einfach diesen Verein leben, die auch diese Gier anscheinend so tief in sich drin haben, dass sie sagen, mir ist es egal, dann gewinnen wir halt eben neun Titel in Serie. Aber wir holen die Dinge halt. Und dann haben sie halt mittlerweile, falls wir noch kurz auf den Kader kommen, muss man schon auch sagen, also diese Saison, und da würde ich jetzt Cristiano Ronaldo logisch ein spezieller Punkt, aber auch neben Ronaldo ist schon, also in der Breite ist schon brutal, was die teilweise da mittlerweile rumlaufen haben, gerade was die Offensivabteilung anbelangt. Und Allegri schafft es gut, die gut miteinander zu rotieren, dass da jetzt keiner zu oft draußen sitzt und zu oft dann vielleicht schlechte Laune hat. Ja, und dann kann so was anscheinend rauskommen.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Ich meine, es sind erst acht Spähtage gespielt, aber trotzdem ist es einfach beeindruckend. Ich habe natürlich auch gleich mal geguckt, wie steht eigentlich Cristiano Ronaldo so in der Torjäger-Statistik da. Und da sieht man unerkannte Schwächen bisher, erst bei vier Treffern. Aber ein Name hat mich umgehauen. Und als ich dann ein bisschen hinterher gegoogelt habe, habe ich gesehen, oje, hinter dem ist er ganz Europa her. Ich war glaube ich der Letzte, der das Memo bekommen hatte. Christoph Piatek von Genua. Neun Tore in sieben Ligaspielen, in acht Pflichtspielen, unfassbare 13 Tore. 13 Tore in acht Pflichtspielen. Was ist da los?
Ja, der gute Mann hat bis jetzt in dieser Saison in jedem Pflichtspiel, in dem er gespielt hat, getroffen. Der Name war jetzt nicht nur dir, nicht vor der Saison.
Nennen Sie ihn schon den italienischen Alcasa?
Ja, der Punkt ist halt, dass sich dadurch in den letzten Wochen einfach so ein brutaler Hype aufgepausch hat, dass der Genua-Präsident, das ist Enrico Preziosi, das ist ein sehr großer Spielzeugwarenhersteller in Italien. Einer der größten, der auch mit seinem Verein manchmal wird ihm manchmal vorgeworfen, etwas Spielzeughandel betreibt. Dass der jetzt erstmal so medial ein bisschen auf den Tisch gehaut hat und so gemeint hat, so liebe Leute, ich erzähle euch jetzt mal, wie das ist. Ich werde ungefähr jeden Tag bombardiert. Er wird gemeint, ich glaube, er wird so quasi bedrängt, sozusagen aus ganz Europa und wirklich aus ganz Europa. Deswegen wollte er jetzt nur erstmal klarstellen, dass der A keine Klausel hat, dass so B im Winter nicht gehen wird und dass ERC den Preis festlegt. Also es hat sich wirklich in den letzten Wochen, in diesen ersten Wochen von Spiel zu Spiel, okay, erst ein Spiel da getroffen, dann Doppelpack, dann noch ein Doppelpack und das ist ein richtig guter Mann, glaube ich, kann man jetzt schon sagen. Noch mal, klar, das sind seine ersten Spieler in Italien, vielleicht schwebt er jetzt auch auf einer gewissen Euphoriewolke, keine Frage, aber wenn man ihn sich so anschaut, dann ist das schon ein sehr kompletter Mittelstürmer. Der hat auf jede erdenkliche Weise schon getroffen, Kopfballstark, sehr, sehr guten Abschluss innerhalb des Strafraums, außerhalb des Strafraums auch schon und der scheint auch diesen Willen zu haben, dass er logisch weiß, das war jetzt das perfekte Sprungbrett, das er logisch hat. Das hat Preziosi auch gesagt, klar weiß ich, dass ich den nicht ewig halten kann, aber angeblich ist so die erste Preismarke, die momentan durch den Raum schwirrt, die hängt bei 60 Millionen Euro. Das Preisschild hat jetzt angegeben, Preziosi.
Er ist 23 Jahre alt, hat jetzt mal acht Spiele in Folge immer eine Bude gemacht. Da bin ich fast überrascht über so einen günstigen Preis.
Ja, und der Punkt ist, es ist relativ einfach, wie du gesagt hast, in Italien sind alle Großen schon dran. Napoli hat sich jetzt sogar aus dem Fenster gelehnt, der Laurentes hat schon offen gesagt, ja, da werde ich meinen Kollegen Preziosi, ich habe schon mit ihm gesprochen, ich werde auch noch mit ihm sprechen. Also die bauen da ein bisschen auf die polnische Fraktion bei ihnen. Die haben ja Mielik und Cielinski schon da, die hoffen da, dass der denen ein paar nette Sachen erzählt. Juve ist dran, die Mailanders sind dran, die Engländer sind dran. Ich glaube, aus Deutschland hat es geheißen, Dortmund schaut sich den auch mal einfach mal so an.
Bayern kann natürlich nicht, weil Lewandowski ja sein Konkurrent ist.
Genau, vielleicht, oder wer weiß. Aber auf jeden Fall, ja, sicherlich so ein bisschen das Märchen der ersten Serie-A-Wochen.
Ja, und vor allem deshalb ja so ein bisschen verwunderlich, weil er ist jetzt 23 und er kam eben erst, wie du es gesagt hast, jetzt zu dieser Saison von Krakau zu Genoa. Das heißt, das ist jetzt quasi die erste europäische Top-Liga, in der er spielt, und dann legt er gleich so los. Das ist schon so ein bisschen so eine Miroklose-Geschichte, so out of nowhere, auf einmal war er da.
Keine Frage.
Macht jetzt 13 Tore in 8 Spielen. Gucken wir an, wie es weitergeht. Wenn ich mir aber Genoa generell angucke, dann sehe ich die auf Platz 12. Ich sehe, dass arg viele andere Menschen nicht getroffen haben, außer Piatek. Also 12 Tore. Davon hat er 9 gemacht. Das würde ich als Abhängigkeit bezeichnen.
Da kann man, glaube ich, das Wort Abhängigkeit in den Mund nehmen.
Und so kommt es dann auch zu vier Siegen und drei Niederlagen. Ist das auch ungefähr das Leistungsniveau von Genoa? Und sie stehen wegen Piatek noch im Mittelfeld? Oder wie würdest du das einschätzen?
Genoa war eigentlich die letzten Jahre immer so eine Mannschaft, die hat, wenn es funktioniert, die haben immer ein paar interessante Leute dabei. Die haben jetzt zum Beispiel Domenico Crescito zurückgeholt, der stammt aus Genoa, der lange bei Zenit St. Petersburg war, der spielt eine wichtige Rolle, ist da jetzt auch gleich wieder Kapitän, ist auch in der Nationalmannschaft. Genoa ist eigentlich relativ bekannt dafür, dass die immer wieder interessante Leute rausbringen, auch meistens einen relativ ansehnlichen Fußball spielen lassen. Das Problem bei Genoa –und da kommen wir wieder zum Präsident Prezioso zurück –ist, dass der sehr gerne jeden Sommer die Mannschaft so ein bisschen, ich sage mal, auf den Kopf stellt, weil er dann einfach fünf verkauft und sieben neue holt, um jetzt einfach mal zwei Zahlen in den Raum zu werfen. Und das logischerweise der Beständigkeit jetzt nicht unbedingt zuträglich ist. Aber eben wie gesagt, da kommen immer wieder Leute raus, die zumindest große Hoffnungen wecken. Und deswegen allein das Stadion in Genoa, Genoa ist auch die Geschichte einer der ältesten Vereine. Genoa spielt auf jeden Fall, würde ich sagen, ist aus der Serie A definitiv wegzudenken. Und jetzt Beatec Hien oder Beatec Heer, die, glaube ich, werden auch diese Saison nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun haben.
Und bei der Tapelmposition muss man noch dazu sagen, genauso wie Milan fehlt Genoa noch ein Spiel wegen der eingestürzten Brücke damals. Das heißt, es könnte auch noch mit einem Sieg, da würde ich jetzt noch drüber sprechen, warum sind die auf Platz 4?
Genau, und vier Siege in sieben Spielen sind jetzt aus Genoas Sicht ganz sicher sehr, sehr ordentlich.
Wahnsinn, sehr, sehr ordentlich ist natürlich auch das, was der SSC Neapel bisher abgeliefert hat. Wir haben es schon angesprochen, es gab die Niederlage gegen Juve. Ansonsten folgte noch eine weitere, der Rest wurde allesamt gewonnen. Und das ja alles Jahr mit einem neuen Trainer, der nicht so ganz unbekannt sein dürfte, mit Carlo Ancelotti. Wie hat er sich denn eingefügt in Napoli?
Ja, also mit einem Wort sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gut. Das waren jetzt Mehrwörter, mein Fehler. Ja, hat wunderbar funktioniert. Also man muss dazu vielleicht einen ganz kleinen Vorschub. Maurizio Sarri hat logischerweise das, was er mit Napoli geschafft hat die letzten Jahre, den Fußballstil, den er einfach geprägt hat, hat er wirklich in ganz Europa auch. Man muss nur mal bei Herrn Guardiola nachfragen. Der erzählt einem sehr, sehr viele und sehr schöne Sachen über Sarri und Sarris Fußball. Das steht außer Frage. Der Punkt ist halt, dass der Laurentis schon immer wieder, während der Zeit der Präsident, so ein bisschen auf Kriegsbus mit ihm, weil er halt gemeint hat, ja, das ist alles schön und gut, was wir da spielen, aber wir holen halt keinen Titel. Und zweitens, du spielst halt immer mit denselben 12, 13 Mann. Wir haben ja mittlerweile auch in Japen einen breiten Kader und ich möchte da eigentlich schon, dass auch die Jungen und so spielen. Deswegen ging das am Ende, was eigentlich sehr, sehr schade ist. Relativ, sage ich mal, nicht so schön zu Ende. Diese Ehe zwischen, muss man dazu sagen, aber zwischen De Laurentiis und Sarri. Und vom ersten Tag an, als dann De Laurentiis Angelotti präsentiert hat, war so ungefähr, wurde er von De Laurentiis als der Messias angekündigt. Das ist jetzt ein Mann, der hat alles schon gewonnen. Der hat die riesen Erfahrungen, auf den kann ich mich blind verlassen.
Der hat aus Bayern eine Spitzenmannschaft gemacht.
Ja, dieses Kapitel wurde jetzt vielleicht ausgeblendet, wobei man da ja vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen sollte, wenn man sich mal rückblickend anschaut, was Ancelotti geholt hat. Und was Heinkes dann geholt hat, da ist gar nicht so viel Unterschied. Also nur um die Ergebnisse.
Genau, auch wenn du jetzt auch einen anderen Trainer mit ähnlichen Problemen siehst, da könnte man auch durchaus mal dann doch noch mal über die Mannschaft sprechen.
Das war nicht aufmachen, keine Frage. Das hat dann am Ende nicht mehr gepasst. Aber ich glaube, das, was er da vorhin in München gemacht hat, war jetzt nicht das Aller-Aller-Schlechteste so. Deswegen hat er von Anfang an riesen Vorschussloberen gehabt. Das hat er in den ersten Monaten schon sehr bestätigt. Er hat das sehr clever gemacht. Er hat auch von Anfang an gesagt, ich will es vielen guten, dass die Mannschaft unter Sarri einstudiert hat. Die will ich in keinster Weise zerlegen. Ich möchte nur zwei, drei kleine neue Impulse setzen. Was er dann definitiv anders macht als Sarri, er gibt dem ganzen tiefen Kader, den Napoli definitiv auch, hat schon seit zwei, drei Jahren, Minuten, und zwar sehr viele. Bis jetzt war es im Schnitt so, dass er von Spiel zu Spiel manchmal bis zu fünf, manchmal sogar sechs, einmal hat er sogar acht Mann gewechselt, von einem Spiel zum nächsten.
Da müssten andere Träne ihren Kopf hinhalten.
Richtig, aber es funktioniert. Er, Neapel, wie du eben sagst, dieses eine, sie haben sehr deutlich 0-3 im Genre bei Sampdoria verloren. Das ist logischerweise ein krasser Ausrutscher, aber der kann halt vielleicht auch einmal passieren. Genau, richtig. Die Niederlage in Turin, ich sag mal so, in Turin verlieren andere Mannschaften auch. Und der Rest war sehr, sehr beeindruckend, weil er es nämlich geschafft hat. Er hat eine kleine Systemumstellung gemacht. Er ist von diesem dogmatischen 4-3-3 erst mal zum 4-4-2 zurück, hat gesagt, ich möchte, dass die Mannschaft auch ein bisschen defensiv Sicherheit sich holt, was anhand der Gegentore sehr gut funktioniert. Und das Zweite, das war sicher sein entscheidender Move bisher, er hat Insinje vom Flügel ins Zentrum reingestellt als einen der zwei Stürmer, der wirklich direkt vor dem Tor ist, weil er gesagt hat, ich möchte, dass er seine Abschlussqualitäten einbringt und ich möchte, dass er nicht mehr so viel Energie auf dem Flügel auch durch das Arbeiten nach hinten sozusagen einpüst. Und das funktioniert bomba. Insinje hat, glaube ich, jetzt schon 7 oder 8 Buden gemacht, hat brutales Selbstvertrauen, den Abschluss eben hat er und das war sicher bis jetzt so der Clue-Move, um da seine eigene kleine Handschrift schon einzugeben in die Mannschaft, aber trotzdem, bis viele gute das hier hatte, einfach weiterhin laufen zu lassen.
Beeindruckend zu das Spiel vielleicht, habe ich auch nur 90 Minuten gesehen, das Heimspiel gegen den FC Liverpool in der Champions League, da ist mir eben aufgefallen, es war das alte Pressing, was man auch unter Sache gesehen hat, und zwar so, dass Liverpool, die haben keinen Stich gemacht. Also es war unglaublich, wie harmlos Liverpool in diesem Spiel war. Und in den Momenten, die Napoli hatte, waren sie brandgefährlich. Und dann war das ein relativ spätes Tor, es hätte aber auch schon viel früher fallen können. Und vor allem ab dem 1 zu 0 war völlig klar, hier wird nichts mehr gehen, weil eben diese defensive Stabilität da war. Und da habe ich aus der letzten Saison schon gerade dann in der Phase, wo dann Napoli dann nach diesem Juve-Spiel, haben sie ja glaube ich direkt 2 zu 2 oder 1 zu 2 gespielt.
Sie glaube ich sogar direkt in Florenz, da ist er deutlich verloren.
Stimmt, es war noch höher.
Ja, 3-0 haben sie sogar verloren.
Und da war das nämlich, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, die waren sehr sehr anfällig, wenn das Pressing nicht gegriffen hat. Und das ist mir zumindest in diesem einen Spiel aufgefallen. Das Pressing war noch da, aber auch die Absicherung dazu. Und das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Keine Frage. Und du sagst es ja genau, dieses Liverpool-Spiel ist logischerweise stellvertretend dafür. Denn man muss das gegen Liverpool, gegen diese Offensive schon erst mal hinkriegen, dass die mehr oder weniger ja fast keine richtig große Torchancen haben. Jetzt kann man sicher sagen, das war sicher auch so, dass der Liverpool alles andere als seinen besten Tag hatte. Keine Frage. Aber ich bin halt immer der Meinung, das hängt halt auch ein bisschen vom Gegner ab. Und das lag halt auch daran, dass Neapolitan einfach relativ wenig gegeben hat. Und deswegen ist das, sage ich mal, das Neue an Charlotte Napoli, ist genau das, was du gerade gesagt hast. Viel von dem, von diesem einstudierten, von diesem blinden Verständnis, dass die Spieler einfach über die letzten Jahre aufgebaut haben, ist da. Dazu eine kleine Dosis vielleicht defensiv, Aufmerksamkeit mehr, ein Insidio näher am Tor und alle Spieler, die wirklich auf Einsatzzeiten kommen. Dementsprechend auch wirklich, da findest du, in Neapol wird du momentan keinen einzigen finden, der momentan irgendwie unzufrieden ist. Und deswegen ist das sehr, sehr gut angelaufen für Ancelotti.
Ein sehr beeindruckender Start. Und beeindruckend ist auch, wenn man sich das mal näher anguckt, die Champions League-Balance der Serie A-Vereine. Wir haben bisher nur über Vereine gesprochen, die noch nicht verloren haben. Und wenn wir jetzt über Inter Mailand, den dritten in der aktuellen Tabelle, sprechen werden, dann sprechen wir wieder über ein Team, das gegen Tottenham 2 zu 1 gewonnen hat. Und dann in Eindhoven auch. Also läuft auch international. Und in der Liga zwei Niederlagen, eine davon am allerersten Spieltag für Inter. Wie haben die sich berappelt? Wie würdest du die einschätzen nach acht Spieltagen?
Ja, du hast das schon genau richtig gesagt. Bei Inter war dieser Turnaround dieses Champions League-Heimspiel gegen Tottenham. Die sind ja wirklich sehr gefährlich gestartet, weil sie haben ja nicht nur das erste verloren, sie haben dann auch noch daheim gegen –also sie haben in Sao Paulo verloren und dann auch noch zu Hause gegen Parma, was logisch am Anfang eine üble Nummer war. Da unter Druck in Mailand ist schnell sehr groß, die Erwartungshaltung an Inter ist riesig.
Aus den ersten vier Spielen dann eben nur ein Sieg. Also hätten wir nach vier Spieltagen schon aufgenommen, hätte ich dich ganz anders zu unterdrücken.
Keine Frage, genau. Und dann kam dieses Tottenham-Spiel, das war dieses –darf man nicht vergessen –das war das erste Champions League-Spiel seit dem Triple, seit Mourinho.
Seit 2010.
Die waren jetzt, ich meine, diese San Siro Stadien, Inter, diese Begeisterung, die waren halt einfach komplett weg von dieser Champions League-Landkarte. Und dann kommen die da in dieses Stadion zurück, es war wahnsinnig emotional, es war voll, es war laut. Sind dann liegend zurück, müssten das Spiel eigentlich auch verlieren oder zumindest nicht gewinnen, vielleicht ein Unentschieden wäre schon okay gewesen. Ja, und dann packen die diese letzten Minuten aus, diese brutale Bude von Icardi, dieser Wolleabschluss und dann machen die nach Spielzeit 2-1 und dann hat man wirklich auch gemerkt, ich finde es gibt ja manchmal so Momente, wo du merkst, da kann nochmal, wir sind jetzt im Oktober, da passiert noch sehr viel, keine Frage, aber da hast du wirklich gemerkt zwischen Emotionalität im Stadion, das war auch schon brutal laut nach dem 1-1, das war Wahnsinn, dann machen die dieses 2-1, da hast du echt das Gefühl gehabt, das Ding kommt runter und ab da läuft, muss man einfach sagen, weil die Qualität ist da, darüber brauchen wir nicht reden, die hatten die letzten Jahre schon viel Qualität, die haben jetzt noch mal mit 9-Goll an, Mitte frei von Lazio, also die haben schon gut vorne draufgepackt und das war dieses Klick und seitdem haben sie jetzt jedes Spiel gewonnen, haben jetzt den Rückstand, der ja so früh schon 8 Punkte auf Juve war, jetzt erst mal konserviert, weil sie halt einfach diese Siegeserie angezogen haben und ja, ich glaube die Tabelle, so wie sie momentan da steht, Ist auch die, also Napoli und Inter, bin ich mir glaube ich sehr fest dran, sind auf jeden Fall die größten Juvejäger. Keine Frage.
Ja, und wenn ich jetzt auf das Wochenende vorausblicke, dann sehe ich da ein ganz interessantes nächstes Spiel für Inter gegen Milan, Derby. Und das gibt uns die Gelegenheit, mal über Milan zu sprechen. Die stehen aktuell auf Platz 10, haben allerdings auch noch das fehende Spiel. Das heißt, da könnte es mit dem Sieg gegen Genua auch in die ersten vier der Tabelle hochgehen. Wo würdest du Milan denn einordnen, die ja mal wieder eine sehr, sehr turbulente Sommerpause hatten, zwischenzeitlich vom Europa Cup ausgeschieden? Jetzt haben sie einen 120 Millionen Euro Verlust gemeldet. Der Besitzer hat gewechselt. Das alles ist passiert bei Milan. Was machen sie denn sportlich?
Also das alles muss man vielleicht auch kurz einordnen. Das gehört schon dazu. Die Zahlen, die du gesagt hast, die sind A, vollkommen richtig und B, auch sehr aktuell. Dieses Pilanzminus, dieses Große. Man muss aber auch dazu sagen, das zeigt noch, das ist noch dieses Bild der Vergangenheit. Und nämlich seit die Amerikaner jetzt eben da im Sommer eingestiegen ist, ist da definitiv viel mehr Stabilität reingekommen. Also dieser chinesische Eigentümer, der davor da war, auch sehr fragwürdig. Deswegen ging das ja am Ende auch nicht mehr gut. Deswegen auch dieses Minus noch aus dem letzten Jahr. Das wäre definitiv nicht in die richtige Richtung gegangen. Aber dieses amerikanische Management, dieser Hedgefond, der da eingestiegen ist, scheint sehr viel Stabilität gebracht zu haben. Das zeigt sich auch alleine an den Namen Maldini und Leonardo, die auch damit eingestiegen sind. Gerade Maldini wurde seit, kann man sagen, glaube ich seit 15 oder 20 Jahren, wurde der von Milan manchmal, glaube ich, auch auf Knien angebettelt. Komm doch bitte zurück, um das, was du bist, einfach auch in den Verein wieder einzubringen. Aber Maldini war halt einfach viel zu intelligent, viel zu smart, um zu erkennen, dass da halt einfach mit dem Verein noch so viel im Argen ist, dass er immer gesagt hat, nee, nee.
Und welche Funktion hat er jetzt? Cattuso ist ja weiter Trainer.
Jaja, klar. Er ist im Prinzip so eine Art Sportdirektor, Sport, wobei das eigentlich Leonardo auch ist. Ja, so eine Art sportlicher Generaldirektor, wie auch immer. Ich glaube, er ist einfach, das Wichtigste ist halt einfach. Und deswegen spreche ich es an, dass Maldini jetzt die Zusage gegeben hat, war für mich allein schon Signal, dass das jetzt finanziell oder wirtschaftlich in eine stabile Richtung geht. Weil Maldini das sonst nicht gemacht hätte. Der hätte das in den letzten Jahren, wie gesagt, schon zehnmal machen können. Der hätte da nur an die Tür klopfen müssen. Die hätten ihn jedes Mal mit offenen Armen empfangen. Aber jetzt anscheinend scheint einfach wirklich auch eine gewisse finanzielle Stabilität da zu sein oder zu kommen mit diesen Amerikanern. Und ja, Gattuso, du hast angesprochen, war ja auch sehr skeptisch. Am Anfang wurde er beäugt. Klar, zu Recht auch, er hat jetzt noch nicht viel vorzuweisen, aber man muss sagen, der hat die Mannschaft richtig gut im Griff. Man denkt dann in den Spieler Gattuso und auch dieses Wollen-Biss-Kampf-Laufen, das stimmt schon. Aber er hat jetzt der Mannschaft auch schon vielleicht Ende der letzten Saison und jetzt auch über den Sommer schon auch ein klares fußballerisches Konzept verordnet. Und deswegen, wie du es eben sagst, momentan ist Platz 10, aber wenn sie das Nachholspiel gewinnen, sind sie nur ein Punkt hinter Inter, also eigentlich alles gut. Läuft das? Mein Higuain ist logisch eine Versicherung einfach. Da weißt du, wenn du diesen Mann holen kannst, dann hast du eine gewisse Anzahl an Toren. Das liefert er jetzt ja auch schon. Suso macht einen sehr guten Job. Der spanische Offensiv außen, der jetzt ja auch für die Nationalmannschaft, zur Nationalmannschaft einberufen wurde. Und dann, klar, es gibt viele Spieler, über die man da reden könnte, aber Cutrone, eben der junge Italiener, der da im Hintergrund ist, der scheint auf einem sehr guten Weg zu sein. Der hat jetzt schon sehr oft sehr viele verbale Schulterklopfer bekommen, auch von Inza.
Sie haben den Vertrag mit ihm verlängert, aber erst jetzt im Nachhinein gesagt.
Ja, genau. Und man darf ja nicht vergessen, allein die Tatsache, dass Milan sich im Sommer von Bacca, also dem kolumbianischen Nationalspieler, von Kalinic und von Andres Silva, dem portugiesischen, getrennt hat, zeigt, dass sie an Cutrone glauben. Und ich glaube, alleine die Tatsache, dass der jetzt von Higuain lernen kann, ist nicht die schlechteste Konstellation für einen jungen Angreifer, der jetzt ja auch schon hätte eigentlich bei der Nationalmannschaft dabei sein sollen, zum ersten Mal, war dann leider angeschlagen, war jetzt nicht dabei. Aber Milan macht das, finde ich, ziemlich gut, auch in der Abwehr. Viele relativ junge Italiener, da ist auch so ein bisschen die Zukunft, glaube ich, der italienischen Nationalmannschaft. Läuft vieles bei Milan rum und ich traue Milan definitiv zu, dass die da vorne in den Rennen, dann eben auch mit der Roma, mit Inter Napoli, sind ja nur vier Plätze, also da wird wieder einer draußen bleiben, aber ich traue Milan definitiv zu, dass die da eine ordentliche Rolle, klar, dann auch in Richtung Champions League quali.
Einzige Niederlage am ersten Spieltag auswärts in Neapel, war natürlich auch sehr, sehr schwerer Auftakt seitdem nur gewonnen oder unentschieden gespielt, nämlich beides dreimal und so kommt jetzt dann eben dieser Platz zustande. Das wird ein interessantes Mal in der Derby. Das kann man, glaube ich, so festhalten.
Vor allen Dingen, um das kurz abzuschließen, weil die wirklich auch beide so ein bisschen auch auf dem aufsteigenden Ast sind. Ich meine, das war nicht schwierig nach den letzten Jahren, weil man darf so lange Jahre keine Champions League inszenieren. Das ist schon eine Wahnsinnsgeschichte. Aber jetzt, ich glaube, dass die beide auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise, aber auf einem sportlich guten Weg sind.
Sehr, sehr gut. Da weiß man doch, was man sich zu Gemüte führen kann am Wochenende. Wenn ich mir die Tabelle weiter angucke, dann sehe ich vor allem noch eine Mannschaft, die ich jetzt gerne sprechen würde, weil man sieht, als Aussteiger ist Parma Calcio aktuell auf Platz 9, mit vier Siegen, einem unentschieden, drei Niederlagen. Ist das eine Momentaufnahme? Könnte das eine Überraschung werden? Wie würdest du das einordnen?
Es ist ja erstmals schon mal eine sehr schöne Geschichte, dass Parma wieder da ist. Denn Parma allein wegen Namen, glorreiche Vergangenheit, da fallen einem ja doch ein paar Namen ein, wie Buffon, Toram, Cannavaro, Asprea, also Verona. Da liefen ja doch ein paar Leute rum vor ein paar Jahren, das noch gar nicht so lange her ist. Ja, das ist schon sehr angenehm war, anzuschauen. Und das Schöne ist ja, dass die eh schon Geschichte geschrieben haben, denn die als erste italienische Mannschaft gelungen, durch drei Aufstieg in Serie A, in die Serie A zurückzukehren. Die hatten ja diesen Crash damals auch finanziell. Und deswegen war das schon schön. Und dass die jetzt logisch so starten auch noch, damit war auch nicht unbedingt zu rechnen. Aber Parma –und das ist logisch der Mann, der überall momentan raussticht –die haben diesen Herrn Gervinho aus China zurückgeholt, wo sehr viele gespunstelt haben und sich gedacht haben, na klar, da holt man jetzt aus China einen abgehalfterten, alten was auch immer zurück. Ja, dieser Herr Gervinho hat mal den ersten Spieltag ordentlich durch die italienischen Plätze, über die italienischen Plätze gewirbelt und hat vor kurzem auch eine Bude geschossen, wo er mehr oder weniger im eigenen Strafraum gestartet ist und so ungefähr an Alten vorbeigelaufen ist, die ihm in die Quere kamen. Da wurden dann auch Vergleiche zum George Werthor vor sehr vielen Jahren für Milan gezogen. Also, ja, das war logisch schnell.
Interessant, das ist in Deutschland immer das Matthäus Tor gegen Jugoslawien.
Das ist dann das Werthor, genau, richtig. Und ja, hat eingeschlagen, wie, weiß sonst nichts, scheint dieses Tempo nicht verloren zu haben. Das sind mal vor ein paar Jahren so einen sehr, sehr, sehr begehrten Spieler in Europa, in ganz Europa gemacht hat und ist so jetzt ein bisschen das Gesicht. Aber das Schöne ist ja, dass bei Parma wirklich auch noch einige Spieler dabei sind, die momentan auch stamm sind, die teilweise diesen Aufstieg, also gerade den letzten, mitgemacht haben und die haben das sehr clever gemacht. Die haben sich dann eben so ein paar Zuckerlader zugeholt, wie Gervino. Ich meine, dass das dann so funktioniert, glaube ich, haben die sich vielleicht erträumt, aber konnte man nicht rechnen.
Barca hatte das in der letzten Saison. In dieser Saison hat es vielleicht ein bisschen Börse Dortmund mit Witzel. Du holst jemanden aus China und...
Genau, muss dann halt, ja, passt halt alles. Aber sie haben auch sonst einen interessanten Kader. Sie haben zum Beispiel, sie sind so eine kleine Lai-Dependence von Neapel geworden, haben sich vier oder fünf Spieler aus Neapel geholt. Darunter eben auch ein ganz interessanter Mann, Roberto Inglese, der Mittelstürmer, der eigentlich, ja, schon beeindruckende Zahl in den letzten Jahren, schon in Italien, der war lang bei Chievo, hat da sehr viel gebombt. Neapel hat ihn geholt, hat nie wirklich eine Chance bekommen, was eben wenige verstanden haben, das war auch so eine kleine Sariennummer. Und der ergänzt sich jetzt wunderbar mit Gervinho. Die rocken das im Prinzip da vorne, der macht die Bälle fest, verteilt die gut, knipset selber hin und wieder und öffnet sonst Räume für Gervinho. Und die Gervinho sehr gerne mit sehr viel Tempo reingeht. Und deswegen, ja, das ist eine sehr schöne kleine Geschichte. Bruno Alves hinten drin, den kennt man glaube ich auch noch, ein portugiesischer Innenverteidiger, der ist gleich Kapitän geworden. Ja, so eine kleine, interessante Truppe, die das sehr, sehr gut macht. Und die, man braucht ja nur die Tabelle anschauen, das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht auf diesem Niveau unbedingt weitergehen, aber allein das Punktepolster, das sie sich schon geholt haben gegenüber dem Rest da hinten drin, davon werden die, glaube ich, noch lange zehren. Und ich glaube, dass die alle Möglichkeiten haben, vielleicht mal eine relativ ruhige Saison zu spielen.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Was für eine Geschichte. Auch noch mal die Transferhistorie von Cervindu. Ich habe sie mir noch mal aufgerufen. Das ist halt einfach irre. Also fangen wir mal bei Lille an, sagen, da ging es so los. Dann zu Arsene, das ist das, woran man sich noch erinnern kann. Dann beide Roma und von Rom dann eben im Jahr 2016 nach China. Jetzt kommt er wieder zurück. Er war dann bei verschiedenen chinesischen Klubs, aber da will ich jetzt nicht so tun, als würde ich die kennen. Und jetzt kommt er zurück und schlägt so ein. Das ist doch eine schöne Geschichte, was vielleicht auch eine ganz interessante Geschichte zumindest sein könnte. Was macht Kevin Pinspoateng bei Sao Solu? Die haben ja am ersten Spieltag, glaube ich, gleich vor Aufsehen.
Die haben gleich mal hintergeschlagen. Genau. Was sie in den letzten Jahren schon sehr gerne und sehr regelmäßig tun. So ungefähr mindestens einmal pro Saison, manchmal sogar zweimal. Ja, sehr gut macht er sich. Sowohl auf dem Platz als auch abseits des Platzes ist definitiv diese Leader-Rolle, die ihm logisch angedacht war, die füllt er wunderbar aus. Schwermen alle von ihm, auch weil er sich sehr um die Neuen kümmert, die dazukommen, um die Jungen kümmert.
Ist das nicht irre, dass ein Spieler, der selber neu ist im Verein, diese Rolle schon einnehmen kann nach so ein paar Wochen?
Ja, da kommt sicher dazu, dass er eine sehr starke Persönlichkeit einfach mitbringt, auch dieses Selbstverständnis zu sagen, ich komme irgendwo rein und ich möchte da auch gleich Verantwortung übernehmen. Er hat eben erst vor ein paar Wochen ein sehr, sehr großes, sehr interessantes Interview der Gazette dello Sport gegeben, wo er sehr viel erzählt hat. Da kam auch raus, dass er auch bei Milan damals schon gerade mannschaftsintern wichtige Rolle gespielt hat, dass er sich da viel um die Jungen eben gekümmert hat gerade. Und ich glaube, das trägt er einfach in sich. Und wenn dann so einer mit so einem Selbstverständnis zu einem kleinen Verein kommt, wie Sassuolo, der wirklich ein kleiner Verein ist und wo er ja auch definitiv geholt wird mit dem Auftrag, sei du mal bitte unser Leuchtturm, so ungefähr nicht nur sportlich auf dem Platz, sondern auch so, dann nimmt so einer das sehr gerne an und ja, wie gesagt, spielt eine sehr wichtige Rolle. Im 4-3-3 oder 3-4-3 spielt er als falsche Neun. Verteilt sehr gut die Bälle, hat auch schon geknipst. Ja, ist wie gesagt wirklich so das Gesicht dieser Mannschaft auf dem Platz und damit auch das Gesicht einer sehr interessanten Mannschaft. Weil das Volo war die letzten Jahre immer schon, damals unter Di Francesco, der ja da auch den Trainersprung zu Roma geschafft hat. Sehr interessante Mannschaft, die arbeiten da wirklich schon seit Jahren sehr nachhaltig, sehr gut, ruhiges Ambiente, logischer Druck nicht so groß. Viele italienische, junge Spieler, dieses Jahr sind es ein paar weniger, aber sonst letzte Saison gab es auch manchmal Spiele, wo die mit zehn oder einmal sogar mit elf Italienern gespielt haben, was jetzt auch nicht unbedingt typisch ist für die Serie A. Und mit einem sehr, sehr interessanten Mann an der Trainerlinie, nämlich Roberto de Zerbe, das ist ein sehr junger Mann noch, war bis vor ein paar Jahren lang durch die Serie A getingelt, Offensivspieler, sehr kreativ, aber jetzt nicht unbedingt der, der dann nachhaltig sich ganz oben festspielen konnte. Aber als Trainer lässt er sehr unfassbar mutigen Fußball spielen. Die haben glaube ich am dritten oder vierten Spieltag in Turin gegen Juve gespielt und die fahren da hin und spielen Ballbesitzfußball. Das machen die eben, aber halt die Art und Weise auch. Also sehr viel, der Zerbis sagt immer, ich möchte den Ball, ich habe auch keinen Stress, wir können das ganz langsam von hinten rausspielen. Ich möchte aber, dass wir den Ball haben und ich möchte dann nicht, dass wir den blind nach vorne schlagen, sondern wir haben Qualität vorne. Und wenn wir Qualität vorne haben, dann macht das Sinn, dass die Bälle vorne auch sauber ankommen, damit wir damit was anfangen können. Der ist nach Turin gefahren, hat da Fußball gespielt, Ballbesitz-Fußball vor Kurzem in Neapel, dasselbe Spiel. Die haben jetzt zwar beide Spiele verloren, weil die teilweise auch dann nach hinten manchmal anfällig sind, weil die wirklich auch im ganzen Block aufrücken. Aber von der Philosophie her und auch von seinem Dogma, dass er sagt, ganz egal, ob wir daheim gegen Spal spielen oder in Turin gegen Juve, wir spielen unseren Stiefel. Und deswegen gilt er schon ein bisschen als der nächste Mann, den man sich vielleicht im Hinterkopf behalten könnte, der nicht so ganz unerfolgreichen italienischen Trainer riege.
Kann er Deutsch zufällig?
Ich weiß es nicht, ob er Deutsch kann, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ja, wirklich ein sehr interessanter Mann, muss ich sagen. Auf den bin ich gespannt, welchen Weg der auch so die nächsten Jahre geht.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Also drei Niederlagen erst für Sassu Olu liegen aktuell auf Platz 8. Und die Niederlagen waren eben gegen Juve, gegen Milan und gegen Neapel.
Und auch da muss man dazusagen, die haben mitgespielt, gerade Milan, du sprichst es an, da haben sie zwar jetzt kürzlich relativ deutlich dann 1-4 verloren. Das Witzige ist, aber Milan hat sich am Anfang fast hinten reingestellt. Also die haben Abwarten gespielt, die haben Sassu Olu spielen lassen. Und allein das zeigt ja schon mal, dass da schon auch ein gehöriger Portion Respekt hat. Im Prinzip hat Milan die dann zwei, drei Mal auch ausgekontert. Und das allein zeigt schon, dass so ein kleiner Verein sich einfach auch so ein fußballeres Selbstverständnis jetzt arbeitet hat oder auf dem Weg dorthin ist, der sehr vielen ja großen Respekt abverlangt.
Mensch, die Serie A, sie lohnt echt wirklich immer den Blick. Und jetzt haben wir noch gar nicht, das müssen wir jetzt aber dann an der Stelle nachholen, über die Römer gesprochen, sowohl Lazio als auch AS Rom. Lazio haben wir ja verfolgen können bei Eintracht Frankfurt. Er hatte auch den Eindruck, dass ihn nicht so wirklich klar war, auf was sie da zukommen, also von Choreostimmung im Stadion und vor allem, was los war nach dem 1-0 von der Costa. Das hat mich überrascht, dass eine so abgeklärte, abgebrühte Mannschaft, wie es Lazio eigentlich sein müsste, dann doch sich da Beeindruck gezeigt hat und dann kommst du gut einfache Unterzahl, doppelte Unterzahl. Okay, ab dann spätestens wird es schwierig. Letztlich hat man es dann relativ lange ja noch beim 0-3 gehalten und dann kam halt irgendwie noch das letzte Tor. Aber das hat mich gewundert, wenn ich mir jetzt die Tabelle angucke, läuft es in der Liga aber eigentlich ja ganz gut. Platz 4, 5 Siege, 3 Niederlagen. Wo würdest du Lazio denn einordnen, vielleicht auch im Vergleich zu Roma, die ein Pünktchen dahinter steht?
Ja, bei Lazio muss man dazu sagen, so wie die jetzt da stehen, da hätten wir auch, wenn wir vor ein paar Wochen gesprochen haben, hätten wir auch anders geredet. Denn Lazio hat am ersten Spieltag Napoli zu Gast und ist am zweiten Spieltag nach Turin zu Juve gefahren und hat in diesen zwei Spielen genau null Punkte geholt, was logischerweise klar an den Gegner lag, aber das Ambiente jetzt nicht unbedingt beruhigt hat. Wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, dass die nach den sechs Spielen fünf gewonnen haben, dann stehen die jetzt für dieses schwere Auftaktprogramm. Denn die dritte Niederlage, kann man auch gleich dazu sagen, kam im Derby gegen Rom, was sehr, sehr unangenehm ist immer in Rom, weil im Derby verlieren, da bist du halt einfach mal ein halbes Jahr lang einfach der Depp in der Stadt, weil das wirklich sehr, sehr emotional gelebt wird.
Und direkt danach kam dann eben dieses 1 zu 4, was natürlich gegen Rom war.
Genau, aber in der Liga haben sie halt einfach punktenmäßig oder gerade siegemäßig den Turnaround geschafft. Ja, ich tue mich momentan noch ein bisschen schwer, die zu greifen, aber also das würde ich ihnen auf jeden Fall sehr positiv anlassen, weil wie gesagt, darf man nicht vergessen, mit null Punkten aus zwei Spielen starten ist, glaube ich, für jede Mannschaft relativ unangenehm, ganz egal, gegen wen das Auftaktprogramm da ist. Und zum Beispiel auch so ein Milinkovic Savic ist momentan noch nicht der, derer sein kann.
Hat man denn inzwischen seinen Berater mal ausfindig machen können?
Also aus Lati-Sicht ist es gut, dass der kürzlich so wie Morbile bis 2023 unterschrieben hat. Also ich sag mal so, das wird wieder im Winter weitergehen, im Sommer erst recht weitergehen. Aber ich sag mal so, ich weiß nicht, ob wir darüber gesprochen haben, Latios Präsident Lotito ist ein Mann, wenn du bei dem Einkaufen magst, dann bringst du besser einen sehr großen und dicken Geldkoffer mit. Denn dieser Mann wird früher oder später logisch Lazio verlassen. Aber ich bin mir jetzt schon sicher, sobald er Lazio verlässt, wird Lazio ein sehr, sehr dickes Plus auf dem Bankkonto haben. Denn Lotito ist bekannt als einer der härtesten Verhandler. Jetzt hat er auch noch den Joker, dass er sagen kann, hier 2,23, keine Klausel, bring it on, so ungefähr.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Und kurz zur Erklärung, sein Berater ist Matteo Kessmann und der ist eben in diesen belgischen Kurzpass-Skandal verwickelt, über den wir im letzten Kurzpass gesprochen haben. Da soll es beim Wechsel auch tatsächlich von Miljković-Sarvic innerhalb der Belgischen zu Unsauberheiten gekommen sein und seitdem wart er nicht mehr gesehen. Es gilt natürlich trotzdem die Unschuldsvermutung, aber man kann auch den Fakt dastehen lassen, auf einmal war er weg. Wie das manchmal so ist. Okay, das ist Latio und wie ist die Situation bei der Roma?
Ja, die Roma hat einen riesen Umbruch hinter sich im Sommer. Alle so einen Transfer haben noch ein paar auf dem Schirm. Wo man auch jetzt merkt, warum der so viel Geld kostet. Ich glaube, man hat verstanden, dass das ein sehr, sehr klasse Torhüter ist. Ja, Nengo Landweck, die haben wirklich einen riesen Umbruch gemacht.
Ich kann die Zugänge und Abgänge gar nicht alle abscrollen. Das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Das ist auch eine kleine klinische Eigenheit. Aber Fakt ist logischerweise, dass das Monkey eben auch einen großen Umbruch eingeleitet hat. Gewollt oder nicht gewollt, sei mal dahingestellt. Bei so einer Summe muss man Ja sagen. Den hätte man wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel länger halten können. Und dann kam eben die Situation, dass die am Anfang auch gewaltig gestrauchelt haben. Und Rom ist auch, wie gesagt, ein sehr emotionales, sehr heißes Pflaster. Also da ist denen wirklich schon sehr viel um die Ohren geflogen. Ihm und die Francesco auch. Obwohl eigentlich die Francesco nach der letzten Saison mit diesem unfassbar guten Halbfinaleinzug ja eigentlich auch schon ein gewisses Pflaster hat. Aber Gott sei Dank, sage ich jetzt mal, haben sie sich die letzten Spiele gefangen. Ja, wie gesagt, es ist viel Qualität da. Sie haben wieder sehr viele Junge geholt. Kloivert macht es gut. Der Sohn von Patrick Kloivert, Justin, hat am Anfang schon ein paar Mal aufhochen lassen. Ja, wie gesagt, als sie die Roma ist.
Aber kannst du mir erklären, warum die diesen Umbruch angeleitet haben? Also wir erinnern uns an dieses 3-0 gegen Barca im Rückspiel, Champions League, Viertelfinale letzte Saison. Das war das emotionale Highlight. Da haben wir ja auch damals darüber gesprochen in der damaligen Kurzpass-Ausgabe. Und jetzt eben Alisson abgegeben, Nein, Golan abgegeben, der sich jetzt kürzlich sehr verbittert geäußert hat und gesagt hat, er ist deswegen zu Inter gegangen, weil Roma wohl hinter seinem Rücken mit anderen Vereinen über ihn verhandelt hat. Also sprich, es war die Initiative des Vereins, da auszusortieren. Klar, der ist 30, aber von außen betrachtet verstehe ich nicht, warum es jetzt diesen Umbruch geben musste. Ich sehe jetzt nicht, dass der Kader überaltet gewesen wäre. Alisson konnten sie nicht halten.
Genau, richtig.
Aber warum?
Also Alisson kann man schnell abhaken. Ich glaube, wenn ein Spieler in diese auch Gehaltssphären reinkommt, wenn Real mitbietet, wenn die Engländer mitbieten, und da haben sie ja sehr viel Geld daraus gemacht. Also Haken dahinter. Nainggolan, wie du sagst, ist definitiv ein anderer Fall. Schwierig zu sagen. Man muss dazu sagen, Nainggolan wurde in Rom geliebt von allen Fans. Weil es gibt sehr viele Geschichten über ihn. Da sind auch sehr viele wahr, was abseits des Rasens passiert. Aber, das sollte man besser dazu sagen, weil solche Spieler sehr oft einen Stempel bekommen. Der hat auf dem Feld, der hat sich für die Roma zerrissen, der hat fast immer Leistung gebracht, auch in Phasen, wo es für die Mannschaft nicht so lief. Der hat sich sportlich kaum etwas zu Schulden kommen lassen. Dementsprechend hat das das Umfeld schon getroffen. Er erzählt jetzt die Version, es gibt auch die Version, dass er schon ein, zwei Jahre davor auch ein bisschen kokettiert hat. In Rom verdient man gut, auch sehr gut, aber in anderen Orten verdient man auch noch mal ein bisschen besser. Vielleicht war es bei Nainggolan auch die Zeit, dass das ganze Roma-Nainggolan, diese Ehe irgendwann zum Ende kommt. Das ist logischerweise zusammen mit Alisson. Danach wurde auch noch Strothmann abgegeben. Er hatte vielleicht nicht sportlich die allerwichtigste Rolle, aber war mannschaftsintern auch sehr wichtig als Stabilisator. Das ist ihnen am Anfang ein bisschen um die Ohren geflogen. Es wurde sehr viel gemacht, sehr viele junge Leute geholt, die definitiv auch großes Potenzial haben. Nur die Frage ist völlig berechtigt, warum eine Mannschaft, die gerade in der letzten Saison einen sehr stabilen Eindruck gemacht hat und angedeutet hat, dass die auch in so großen Spielen immer wieder für große Sachen sorgen kann, dass man die dann so auseinandernimmt. Definitiv ein Punkt, mit dem sich Monk auseinandersetzen muss oder auch musste. Das einzige Mittel, das dagegen hilft, ist wie zuletzt, ein Derbesieg hilft immer. Die anderen Siege, die zuletzt gefolgt sind, helfen logischerweise auch. Ich traue der Roma auch definitiv zu, dass sie dieses Jahr wieder mit Inter, mit Neapel auch um diese Plätze, an der Juwejagd teilnimmt. Aber irgendwie nicht so ganz einfach zu erklären. Auch muss ich sagen, warum da so viel kommen und gehen ist.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig überblicke, dann ist die Roma auch das einzige italienische Team, das in der Champions League in den bisher zwei gespielten Spielen mal verloren hat. Nämlich auswärts bei Real 0 zu 3. Ich glaube, alle anderen haben ohne Team gespielt oder gewonnen. Da läuft es ja sehr, sehr gut. Es ist jetzt eine Momentaufnahme, sehr wenige Spiele gespielt. Wenn wir so über die Serie A sprechen, habe ich das Gefühl, das ist eine Liga, die hat sich jetzt am eigenen Schopf so ein bisschen aus ihrer sportlichen –nicht Unterklassigkeit ist zu viel, aber man hat international außer Juve, hat niemand eine Rolle gespielt. Das hört sich jetzt so an, als wäre da was im Wandel.
Ja, finde ich. Würde ich jetzt auch gar nicht an diesen ersten zwei Champions-League-Spieltagen aufhängen, das ist jetzt eine Momentaufnahme. Aber ich finde, dieser Wandel, gerade international, ist schon seit zwei, vielleicht drei Jahren zu viel, aber seit ein, zwei Jahren schon zu spüren. Man braucht es nur so denken, Juve klären wir aus. Juve mit Juve ist sehr, sehr vieles möglich, auch in der Champions League. Aber man muss ja nur daran denken, was auch Neapel teilweise in den letzten Jahren in der Champions League immer wieder möglich gemacht hat. Klar, da kam auch nicht viel dabei rum. Einmal mit Sarre sind sie dann auch in der Gruppenphase, in dieser schweren Gruppe mit City und Dinge ausgeschieden. Keine Frage.
Waren der Europa League vor allem so ein bisschen abgeschränkt?
Europa League ist ein eigenes Thema, muss man dazu sagen. Aber ist es doch schwer, 4.
Konto kaufen?
Das ist vielleicht schwer vermittelbar, aber die Europa League, da muss man wirklich zum Beispiel Lazio ein großes Kompliment machen. Die machen das sehr verlässlich, sehr gut. Die hatten letztes Jahr diesen Aussetzer in Salzburg, aber das war halt ein sportlicher Aussetzer. Die hatten da nicht vor, abzuschenken. Die wären da sehr gerne den ganzen Weg gegangen bis ins Finale. Hätte ich ihnen auch auf jeden Fall zugetraut. Napoli hat das damals, wie du gesagt, wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes abgeschenkt. Diese Europa League hat halt einfach nicht diesen Stellenwert in Italien. Aber noch Champions League, finde ich, hat sich schon angedeutet. Und das sieht man jetzt diese Saison. Juve, klar. Neapel, finde ich, allein die Tatsache, dass die jetzt in der Gruppe mit Liverpool und PSG da wieder mitspielen, zeigt ja schon, dass da schon ein sehr gehobenes Niveau da ist. Inter war einfach fällig, dass die da endlich wieder reingekommen sind und machen es bis jetzt ja auch gut. Wenn wir Inter auf Stufe 5 momentan sehen, dann gehe ich stark davon aus, dass die Tendenz eher Richtung Stufe 6 als Richtung 4 geht. Also ich glaube, von Inter kann man sich in den nächsten Jahren wirklich auch wieder deutlich mehr erwarten. Das selbe auch von Milan, glaube ich. Das kann auch mit diesen Personen im Hintergrund in die richtige Richtung gehen. Also ich glaube, international stehen die Italiener momentan ziemlich gut da. Und ich glaube auch, dass der Pfeil eher nach oben zeigt. Auch weiter nach oben zeigt.
Wobei du mir irgendwann nochmal erklären musst, warum bei dir die Stufe 6 über der Stufe 4 steht. Aber du meintest, sie steigert sich.
Genau, ich meinte sie stimmmäßig, sondern das Gesetz der größeren Zahl.
Bernie, damit sind wir schon wieder am Ende angelangt. Aber wir haben auch wirklich viel dieses Mal besprochen bekommen. Danke dir, dass du mal wieder hergekommen bist.
Ja, danke dir für die Einladung. Immer wieder sehr, sehr gerne.
Wann hören wir dich das nächste Mal auf der Zone als Co-Kommentator?
Am Wochenende jetzt bei Juve gegen Genua, wo der Herr Piatek wahrscheinlich vor hat, auch seine Serie fortzusetzen.
Dann weiß ich ja auch, was alle Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und –Hörer machen werden, nämlich dir nochmal lauschen und dann im Zuge eines Live-Kommentars. Danke dir, Bernhard, dass du hergekommen bist. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Kurzpass 99. Ihr könnt uns unterstützen auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Dann bleiben wir weiter werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Und wenn ihr das hier fertig gehört habt, gibt es vielleicht schon ein neues Tribüngespräch. Kommt am Freitag raus.